The reason we keep seeing people talking about
a male loneliness epidemic
isn't because men are actually lonely.
It's because a lot of men
are unable to have emotionally intimate relationships.
If you don't have emotional intelligence,
you're not gonna be able to be emotionally vulnerable.
If you can't be emotionally vulnerable,
you're not gonna be able to be emotionally intimate.
And if you can't have emotional intimacy within your relationships,
you are never gonna have a deep,
meaningful connection. And if you don't have deep,
meaningful connections, you're going to feel alone.
The good news is that emotional intelligence skills can be taught.
The bad news is, it is not your romantic partner's job to teach you.